[Musik]
schwere explosionen in der nacht in der
hauptstadt kiew ziel diesmal ein
einkaufszentrum drumherum wohnhäuser
verletzte werden aus den trümmern
gezogen mindestens acht menschen sterben
am morgen wird die zerstörerische wucht
des angriffs sichtbar es ist der 26
tag im russischen angriffskrieg gegen
die ukraine derweil gehen die
diplomatischen bemühungen weiter vor
wenigen stunden hat bundeskanzler scholz
dazu unter anderem mit dem us
präsidenten telefoniert
guten abend willkommen zum zdf spezial
wie so verschiebt sich um etwa zehn
minuten
mit unverminderter härte geht der krieg
in der ukraine weiter im westen des
landes hat russland ein militärisches
ausbildungszentrum mit raketen
angegriffen
dabei sollen 80 soldaten getötet worden
sein die eingeschlossene hafenstadt
mario pohl wird weiter beschossen ein
russisches ultimatum die waffen
niederzulegen hat die ukrainische
regierung abgelehnt die lage der
menschen in der stadt verschlechtert
sich täglich die eu nennt gezielte
angriffe auf zivilisten dort massive
kriegsverbrechen sebastian eben
jeden tag hängt schwarzer rauch über
mario pohl
eine stadt in trümmern in flammen in
schutt und asche seit über drei wochen
bomben jeden tag diese bilder zeigen ein
vorher und
ein nachher
das theater zerstört ein einkaufszentrum
dem erdboden gleichgemacht das
krankenhaus
ausgebombt
mariupol hatte vor dem krieg knapp eine
halbe million einwohner jetzt wird die
stadt zum symbol der zerstörung über die
lage vor ort ist wenig bekannt eine
satelliten analyse aus dem östlichen
teil mario pohl es zeigt die zerstörung
die ukrainische seite schätzt dass 80
prozent der wohngebäude beschädigt sind
ein drittel davon könne man nur noch
abreißen
russland begeht einen echten völkermord
gegen die ukrainische stadt mario pohl
seit drei wochen sind 400.000 menschen
umzingelt ohne nahrungsmittel
trinkwasser elektrizität und fast ohne
verbindung zur außenwelt unter ständigem
raketen und artillerie beschuss
der kreml hatte am sonntag die
kapitulation gefordert bis heute
vormittag sollten die ukrainischen
streitkräfte die stadt aufgeben doch die
ukrainische seite lehnte das ab
mario pohl ist umzingelt
eingekesselt belagert die letzte bastion
zwischen don was und der krim
die hafenstadt strategisch wichtig hält
mario pohl beherrscht russland das ofce
mehr komplett den hafen hat die ukraine
heute geschlossen
der außenbeauftragte der eu wählt
drastische worte
was in mariupol passiert ist ein
massives kriegsverbrechen alles zu
zerstören zu bombardieren und
rücksichtslos zu töten das ist etwas
schreckliches und wir verurteilen das
aufs schärfste
der ukraine dürfte das nicht reichen sie
fordert von der eu vor allem schärfere
sanktionen
in brüssel begrüße ich die vize
präsidentin des europäischen parlaments
guten abend frau war
die eu wirft russland massive
kriegsverbrechen in mario pohl vor wenn
es gerade gehört die welt auch europa
schon ziemlich hilflos zuzusehen oder
täuscht das
die europäische union und die welt haben
eine antwort gegeben die wladimir putin
mit sicherheit so nicht erwartet hat die
europäische union die weltgemeinschaft
ist ganz klar positioniert das ist ganz
klar auf wessen seite praktisch alle
staaten stehen und sie haben maßnahmen
ergriffen mit denen russland mit denen
putin nicht gerechnet hat sowohl auf
wirtschaftlicher seite als auch was die
militärische unterstützung für die
ukraine betrifft wie unterstützt dann
die eu die ukraine ganz konkret und wo
ist die rote linie
es gibt verschiedene arten wie die
europäische union die ukraine
unterstützt das ist erstmal eine
finanzielle wirtschaftliche hilfe von
1,2 milliarden euro das ist aber auch
zum aller ersten mal in der geschichte
der eu dass geld für waffenlieferungen
bereitgestellt wird jetzt die zweite
tranche von 500 millionen also insgesamt
eine milliarde um die ukraine mit waffen
zu versorgen und dann natürlich die
bisher vier sanktionspaket
bundesaußenministerium berbalk sprach
heute von 8 millionen flüchtenden die zu
erwarten sein das ist ja eine riesige
zahl wie wird europa damit umgehen
europa zeigt sich im angesichts der im
angesicht dieser flüchtlingskatastrophe
deutlich beim aufnahmebereite alle
mitgliedsstaaten tun dass das war ja in
früheren
flüchtlingsbewegungen nicht so das heißt
wir werden hier viel viel mehr länder
haben die sich an einer verteilung
beteiligen die hilfsbereitschaft ist
groß wir brauchen jetzt eine eine
entlastung der länder die die
erstaufnahme bewerkstelligt haben polen
in aller erster linie aber auch die
baltischen staaten ungarn slowakei viele
kann man da nennen da werden jetzt
wieder anderen solidarisch sein und ich
hoffe und ich bin optimistisch dass da
auch eine gerechte verteilung erfolgt
vielleicht auch über europa hinaus die
eu steht man kann sagen fast ungewohnt
einig da besteht auch einigkeit darüber
dass jeder mitgliedsstaat jetzt deutlich
mehr tun muss für die klassische
landesverteidigung sprich aufrüsten muss
nun olaf scholz hat in seiner
regierungserklärung ja von einer
zeitenwende gesprochen in deutschland
mit unserer historie mit unserer
geschichte ist das sicherlich ein
besonders großer schritt aber die das
bewusstsein ist in allen mitgliedstaaten
der europäischen union dar es gibt
länder ich nenne jetzt zum beispiel mal
österreich die neutral sind und neutral
bleiben wollen aber eben finnland das
sich der nato annähert und viele länder
die jetzt sehen wir müssen in europa
noch viel stärker zusammenrücken was
sicherheit und verteidigung angeht das
wird jetzt alles ein ganzes stück
schneller gehen als das sonst der fall
gewesen wäre
keinen euro für die besatzer fordert der
ukrainische präsident seelen ski und
meint damit ein einfuhrstopp für
russisches öl wie sieht man dass in der
eu ja da sind die meinungen
etwas geteilt weil wir natürlich länder
haben deutschland gehört dazu aber
deutschland ist dann nicht alleine die
sehr stark abhängig sind von
energielieferungen aus russland italien
ist da zu nennen die slowakei rumänien
gehören auch dazu insofern das sind sich
alle einig dass man bis an die
schmerzgrenze gehen muss wie weit die
geht das ist derzeit noch nicht ganz
klar aber es wird ja in einem fünften
sanktionspaket aktuell gearbeitet und
das wird sich sehr bald herausstellen
ich bin sicher das ist ein sehr
weitgehendes sein mit vielen dank für
das gespräch nach brüssel
und in münster ist uns jetzt
generalleutnant a d karsten jacobs sonst
zugeschaltet guten abend
schönen guten abend war am 1 wir haben
die dramatische lage in mario pohl
gesehen ist die stadt militärisch zu
halten oder ist ihre einnahme durch
russische truppen nur eine frage der
zeit
mario pohl ist wie wir alle in den
letzten stunden gehört haben
eingeschlossen von einer streitmacht die
alle mittel einsetzt die hier zur
verfügung stehen der hafen ist
geschlossen der wert als hafen von mario
pohl ist alleine schon durch die
zufahrtsmöglichkeiten durch die straße
von kertsch und die brücke ohnehin
eingeschränkt so dass mario pohl vor
allen dingen symbolischen wert hat aber
es zeigt natürlich auch wie bereit für
absichtslos rücksichtslose kriegführung
die russische seite hier ist
eine milliarde euro zum ankauf von
waffen wie die eu der ukraine zukommen
lassen so was gab es auch noch nicht wie
kann das das kriegsgeschehen
beeinflussen
nun wir erleben im moment dass mit jedem
tag den dieser krieg länger dauert und
gerade jetzt wo er beginnt in die städte
hinein zu gehen die ukrainische seite
mit jedem tag stärker wird und die
russische seite langsam aber sicher den
art und verliert das ist zu beobachten
es wird vermutlich sehr blutig werden
das ist furchtbar vor allen dingen weil
die russen keinerlei rücksicht auf die
zivilbevölkerung nehmen
danke bis hierher für dieses gespräch
wir sprechen gleich noch weiter
der russische vormarsch ist deutlich
langsamer vorangekommen als
offensichtlich von putin erwartet worden
war von schlechter vorbereitung ist
jetzt die rede von treibstoff und
versorgungsmangel und von altem maroden
gerät da kommt die nachricht vom einsatz
der ultramodernen hyperschall waffe
russland wohl gerade recht was kann
diese waffe was macht sie so gefährlich
axel zimmermann
auch wenn das flugzeug eine russische
mig 31 schon sehr modern aussieht geht
es um die rakete unter ihrem rom die
russische hyperschall rakete kinscher
erregt unter militärexperten große
aufmerksamkeit
kinscher zu deutsch deutsch ist eine
superschnelle rakete die von flugzeugen
auf ziele am boden geschossen wird sie
steuert ihr ziel mit acht bis zehnfache
schallgeschwindigkeit an kann über 1000
kilometer weit fliegen und trifft ihr
ziel mit großer präzision
dabei kann sie konventionelle oder
nukleare sprengköpfe tragen die enorme
geschwindigkeit macht die kindheit so
besonders in einer minute legt die
hyperschall rakete ungefähr 200
kilometer zurück nach dem start steigt
sie auf 18 bis 20 kilometer höhe auf
eine flugbahn in der erdatmosphäre
die ist deutlich flacher als die
bekannten ballistischen raketen
flugbahnen dann fliegt die auf dieser
bahn gut zu steuern die kinder ins ziel
schon zwei mal behauptet moskau habe es
die kinder in diesem krieg verwendet
russland wäre damit weltweit das erste
land mit einer hyperschall rakete ist
die rakete unterwegs ist die zu schnell
um sie zu bekämpfen die beste chance zur
verteidigung wäre das trägerflugzeug
abzuschießen aber das könnte nur eine
leistungsfähige ukrainische luftwaffe
und die hat russland weitgehend zerstört
generalleutnant ad jakobson ist noch mal
bei uns bedeutet der einsatz dieser
hyperschall waffen eine eskalation des
krieges
wir haben ja gesehen dass eine menge
neuer moderner waffen eingesetzt werden
thermo bayerische waffen und die
kindheit die sie eben angesprochen haben
natürlich ist das eine neue qualität die
hier zum einsatz kommt mit dieser
hochleistungs rakete zeigen uns die
russen ihre folterwerkzeuge ist sie
zeigen uns das was sich an militärischen
gerät zur verfügung haben über die
präzision das haben wir in den letzten
stunden gelernt und gelesen kann man
sicherlich noch diskutieren aber eine
waffe die einer entfernung von 1000
kilometer in weniger als zehn minuten
zurückliegt die macht natürlich schon
sorgen und ich könnte mir vorstellen
dass eine amerikanische admiral sich um
einen flugzeugträger jetzt sorgen machen
würde beim einsatz dieser waffe die
nicht abgefangen werden kann insofern
haben wir hier eine neue qualität wir
haben eine neue bedrohung und auch auf
diese wird reagiert werden müssen dieser
überfall auf die ukraine war offenbar ja
als blitzkrieg geplant von kurzer dauer
nur wie lange können sich die kämpfe
denn jetzt hinziehen
nun er ist als blitzkrieg gescheitert
das was russland sich vorgenommen hatte
ist nicht eingetreten und das was im
moment im kreml und mit generalen in der
russischen armee passiert deutet jahren
deutlich darauf hin dass das scheitern
langsam auch erkannt wird nun geht es
leider gottes in die städte in den
städten werden die ukrainer überlegen
sein sie werden mit sicherheit sich
weiter verteidigen aber auch hier gilt
dass wird blutig das wird viele opfer
unter der zivilbevölkerung kosten und
vor allen dingen kann es sehr sehr lange
dauern das sind in jedem fall düstere
aussichten vielen dank für das gespräch
dankeschön
sie den menschen in der ukraine oder
auch auf der flucht helfen wollen
spenden sie bitte an das aktionsbündnis
katastrophenhilfe
stichwort zdf nothilfe ukraine bahn.de
65 104 106 100 104 106 100 alle infos
auch unter spenden punkt zdf.de oder im
zdf text auf seite 8 190
mehr als 120 millionen euro sind bereits
zusammengekommen
wieder antrag der leid und elend
gebracht hat für die menschen in der
ukraine
gespräche laufen zwar auf verschiedenen
ebenen ein durchbruch zu einem
waffenstillstand oder gar einem frieden
ist aber nicht in sicht
zdf heute live diskutiert gleich die
frage scheitert putins krieg mit einem
russischen geheimdienst experten sie
können ihre fragen stellen um 20 uhr in
der zdf- heute- app und auf unseren
social media kanälen mehr informationen
dann später im heute journal und hier
geht es jetzt weiter mit wiso auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]